welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Andor
episode 12 the season finale Rick's Road
and the incredible season of Star Wars
storytelling ended in a finale packed
with hidden details and deeper layers of
meaning no one else is really talking
about including why the writing on
Marvel's brick is actually a huge deal
when you translate it and a secret
change to Marvel's speech that only the
sharpness of lip readers could probably
catch I'm gonna break it all down let's
get started and thanks to boxu for
sponsoring this video more on their
tasty offerings later we open as always
with Nicholas Patel's updated music
[Music]
over a steady drum beat a mix of horns
come together this is the music of
Marvis funeral March that congeals into
a battle charge this episode every
episode of the season has really been
the sounds of Marvis barrick's funeral
band getting them to tune and eventually
playing the same theme a really awesome
parallel now in this episode the product
of this music is what looks like the
earliest open revolt against the empire
in Star Wars history now obviously saw
Guerrera and luthin and Anto Krieger
were involved in all kinds of criminal
plots but like the Boston Massacre in
1770 leading to the American Revolution
this is one early instance where blood
was shed and average folks rose up on
their own we're riding now we're rioting
now we start with this close-up of woman
pox soldering the fuse for the explosive
that'll later throw in this Riot this
mirrors a close-up of the tinkering
droids in the post-credits scene where
they fused the narkina 5 Parts into the
Death Star each side Rebellion an Empire
Building weapons to kill the other
recalling Lutheran's line of being
damned to use the tools of his enemy to
destroy them but really these Sparks and
whiffs of smoke are lighting that fuses
for much more explosive fireworks later
on in time Wilman pack is the son of
Solomon Park whose appearance here glows
in remembrance on woman's desk salmon is
the parts shop owner who hid the radio
for Bix to use and was arrested in
episode 8 and last seen post torture
until Captain Venice Tego took care of
him off screen in episode nine I'd like
to hang him
what's left of him anyway make sure they
know who's in charge as you wish we got
back to woman repeatedly in these
opening minutes as he gingerly assembles
each piece of the device plugging in
cables and twisting them into place each
piece is covered in dirt and grime and
rust a recurring theme in this episode
people
don't look down the way they should
and I look down at Ella pasta Russ there
is a Darkness reaching like rust into
everything to everything around us ah
but woman looks past the rust to
innovate something to hurt the Empire he
finally dials up the charge and the
ascended lights give this the feel of
woman's own handheld Death Star which
would charge up and light up in a
similar way before it would bring utter
destruction
miro's Lambda Class Shuttle lands on
Barracks beside this larger four-winged
vessel this is actually a Zeta class
cargo shuttle first seen in Rogue one
over Jedi and later landed on scarif as
she walks on the deck she's flanked by
death Troopers these are the Troopers
that accompanied krennic in Rogue one's
opening scene and bix's cell the
security camera pivots to face her again
this is the same sixth grid design as
the camera's Hana Chewie shoot out on
the Death Star but it's so unnerving to
be alone in a room with a stationary
camera that suddenly turns to face you
what was your lens not wide enough do
you really need me to be Centered for
your shot right now Zan connects with
Brasso and at first we don't even notice
Zane in the out of focus foreground
blending in with the bricks it's implied
that these bricks are all composed of
dead vaccines and xan will become one of
the casualties of this Riot as they Goss
nurture watches them from the shop where
a speeder is being dismantled it's
painted green and orange or yellow I
thought maybe it could be Anakin speeder
from Attack the Clones or maybe a Pod
racer Tony Gilroy did let his art
Department go crazy with background
references so I'm sure it's something
they also passed the shop where a man in
a bucket hat Tinkers with the Droid I
just love how busy Everything feels on
ferricks nerd she buys xan some drinks
trying to get info from him because we
learn he is a snitch for the Empire
remember he needs this money because he
previously loaned money to Cassian and
cassia never paid him back the really
nurture was a product of cassian's own
mistakes mon matma opens her collar to
breathe this is our green theme on the
series characters being smothered and
choked and otherwise bound either by the
Empire by themselves but all of it a
result of the Empire's tight grip a grip
that as it gets tighter most awesome
slip through its fingers but here mod
confronts her husband parent about its
gambling knowing that her driver Cloris
is eavesdropping on them so was Perrin
actually gambling on one hand she wasn't
surprised when Papa's golden last
episode said that he knew parents
suggesting that Papa Was a lone shark to
parent in the past but think about it
mom is smart enough to know that Cloris
is listening in I think she's throwing
Perrin under the bus to have a plausible
cover story for the missing credits from
her account when the Empire eventually
checks it which would justify why this
honorable Senator would marry off her
daughter to the family of a notorious
crook because later as Clorox reports
the salt of blevin blevin says they've
made some odd banking moves recently
this was certainly explain it I think
think that's why rather than fully
shutting down defensively Perrin has a
valid counter argument this is wrong Mom
this is people trying to take you down
by coming after me and notice how it
legitimately hurts mine to hear a parent
try to explain where these gambling
rumors are coming from deep down she
knows she is one betraying him here and
he probably knows mom referencing Kanto
bite the casino planet from The Last
Jedi you know as we mentioned it Ryan
Johnson's amazing track he shot over the
tables of that casino was in a match to
William a Wellman's tracking shot of the
1927 film Wings one of my favorite
practical shots in which tables and
chairs were pulled apart right as the
camera passed over them also incredibly
unnoticed there is a same-sex couple
there in 1927 and we have come so far
Cassian finds Clem's brick on the wall
covered in Moss and in Roots suggesting
that all the other Memorial bricks are
tidied up by loved ones but since Marva
has died and Cassie has been gone no one
has really clean Clem's brick the
orabesh on that brick is the same font
as the scrapyard sign which reads
zorbies with the letters distorted so
it's kind of hard to tell but here at
the same font translates to Clem Andor
but the birth date above and the death
date below are worn off we got to a
flashback scene young Cassian only from
behind as we did in the flashback before
but we never see young Cassie in space
think about adult casting only remembers
these from what he saw not from how he
looked which is how we all see our
memories Clem says the man that sees
everything he's more blessed than ghost
and he says how most people don't look
past the rest of something but with just
two minutes of cleaning you can find a
diamond in the rough this is the gamut
that Cassian poses to Lutheran at the
end of the episode look past the rest of
me and see how valuable I can be to the
Rebellion passion against run into the
corellian hounds and the scrap yard and
reunites with pelgo back from earlier in
the season played by Kieran O'Brien AKA
Jamie tart's dad on Ted lasso and what
follows is yet another amazing speech on
the series nemec's full Manifesto
passage which we only heard a piece of
last episode but we start with Vixen
with Lutheran there will be times when
the struggle seems impossible I know
this already
alone unsure dwarfed by the scale of the
enemy remember this
freedom is a pure idea it occurs
spontaneously and without instruction
random acts of insurrection are
occurring constantly throughout the
Galaxy there are whole armies but that
have no idea that they've already
enlisted in the cause this
this item being the Natural State in
control being an under
enshrined liberties from tyranny that
humans can impose on each other which is
why the American Bill of Rights the
first 10 amendments is a list of
freedoms as opposed to an enumeration of
Government powers which the rest of the
Constitution was so is nemic a
Libertarian or is he a Marxist both can
be true folks classic political Theory
doesn't have a modern voter registration
so you know maybe don't ban books
Lutheran looks out over the therick's
town which is illuminated by lightning
the distance I love the visuals here
it's like natural forces are charging
this town to the point of explosion and
Luther observes how all of his plans of
an organic Uprising are coming to
fruition mimics voice continues remember
that the frontier of the Rebellion is
everywhere and even the smallest active
Insurrection pushes our lines forward
the Imperial need for control is so
desperate because it's so unnatural
tyridine requires constant effort it
breaks it leaks
Authority is brittle oppression is the
mask of fear remember that yes this is
the section that we heard a snippet of
last episode oppression is the mask of
beer it invokes the mask of Darth Vader
a symbol of Oppression but Assad masking
a fearful brittle broken Soul underneath
fear leads to anger anger leads to hate
hate leads to suck also Imperial control
being unnatural words spoken by
Palpatine himself because after all the
dark side to the force is the pathway to
many abilities some considered to be
unnatural but notice that Cassian tosses
the manifesto aside no longer reading
along as nimik finishes the passage that
they will come when all these skirmishes
and battles as moments of defiance will
have flooded the banks of the Empire's
Authority and then there will be one too
many one single thing will break The
Siege
remember this try try a philosophical
counterpart to Yoda's teachings to Luke
and Dagobah do or do not there is no try
which is an eternally puzzling statement
is effort wasted if it doesn't have a
result no I don't think that's what Yoda
is saying his point is really to stop
focusing on your own inner hurdles and
instead focus on your impact on the
outside world Envision the change you
will inevitably enact and Bridge your
present with your future but I like that
mimic counters Yoda because these Rebels
don't have the luxury of enlightened
Jedi philosophy they don't have the
luxury of future they burn their decency
for someone else's future they burn
their lives to make a sunrise they know
they'll never see trapped in their
present all they have is try the ISB
celebrate their successful trap on Anto
Krieger but it was ever before they
started
prisoners not today you remember young
is a rebel spy who tried to save Anto
Krieger's group but Luke then let them
die to preserve Young status as the spy
and I like how he Twitches his mouth as
he says not today a little subtle
masking of his true feelings in this
moment and by the way Andrew Krieger's
Hollow projection last episode was
designed using the likeness of and or
graphic designer Barry gingo the screen
behind part of gas shows the spellhouse
surface the orbash reads Imperial
saturation which could mean those red
circles are where Stormtroopers are
located clearing out Krieger's group
boxu is hands down the best Japanese
snack subscription they work with family
businesses all across Japan to deliver a
new theme of authentic treats every
month the first box will be Seasons of
Japan but after that you'll get a new
monthly theme just like this one this
month's theme is Autumn mccoyo which is
the Japanese word for the Autumn Leaves
changing colors I just love that there
is a word for that isn't that beautiful
it comes with this booklet that tells
you all the snacks you're eating where
they come from a little information
about all of them what kind of flavors
you can expect what I'm gonna try is a
matcha butter cookie though you know as
I get older I don't really need the
overwhelmingly sweet flavors it's just
all sugar like a bit of a mix a bit of a
texture right
give it a shot
oh that's really good oh that's so good
like the flavor of this thing is not
like anything you're gonna find at like
the corner store it's Unique it's matcha
eat and it's just really nice to savor I
could eat a million of these things you
know what the really nice thing about
boxu is that when you really fall in
love with a snack you can stock up on
your favorites through baksu Boutique
both I and the new Rockstar's office
have been receiving these boxes for ages
and we love them plus every time you get
your box to in the mail you can feel
good knowing that you're supporting
family businesses all the way in Japan
so if you want to try some rare Japanese
snacks with us and support the channel
click the link in the description and
use code rockstars15 to get 15 off your
order core of Watches Over the Andor
home and sees b2emo leave with Zan
wearing brasso's clothes they give them
the slip suppressor meets Cassie and it
gives him marva's final message to him
tell him none of this is his fault
it was already burning it's just the
first Spark of the fire tell him he
knows everything he needs to know and
feels everything he needs to feel and
when the day comes those two pull
together he will be an Unstoppable Force
for good I love him more than anything
he could ever do wrong first Spark you
say no no we are the spark that'll light
the fire that'll burn the first daughter
down but to know everything you need to
know and feel everything you need to
feel
there is no try no what you need to know
is your destined impact in the future
feeling what you need to feel right now
is your present struggle so merging the
subconscious with the conscious our
future with our present is how we become
Unstoppable and fittingly notice how
Marva calls the fusion of the conscious
with the subconscious a force whatever
words these characters are using to talk
about they're talking about the same
thing on the transport musk gives Cyril
his orange hat they swap hats back in
episode 3 Cyril and mosques three more
uniforms included orange build caps for
the officers of this unit while the
others had blue build caps so this is
mosque signaling the cereal that he is
the commander of this Duo the time
Grappler straps the in Bill early and we
cut to the marching band warming up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah their instruments look like
modified French horns and flutes and
Trumpets on the brick wall beside the
daughters of Barracks as orbish graffiti
translating to and or likely in honor of
Marva and or they start the funeral
early to clear more men from the hotel
to lead Bix less guarded this idea of
using a funeral as a cover for a plot is
something that we've seen before from
the Joker in The Dark Knight and from
the seventh Cavalry in HBO's Watchmen in
this sequence has similar tension Rising
beneath as we cut from character to
character it's also something uniquely
prohibited by the purd using a local
cultural custom as a cover for Rebel
activity brassa presents Marvis brick
and again the orbash is distorted in the
font I mentioned earlier but it
translates to Marva Andor and above the
numbers
7895.330.9 that is her birthday and
below
7972.216.4 her date of death and I know
it's rooted to the math here but that
would make Marva 77 at the time of her
death these numbers are hugely
significant because this is the CRC
dating system instead of the BBY and ABY
system that we've typically use and what
this series used in its first episodes
on screen title CRC or hosnian Reckoning
first used in Pablo hidalgo's 2018 scum
and villainy Case Files on the Galaxy's
most notorious and Hidalgo said that
they use this dating system on the brick
because these characters would not know
the Battle of Yavin is coming so Marva
died in 7972 and Princess Leia gets
arrested in 7977 five years from now I
really love this attention to detail
Cassian listens to the music here
[Music]
a gentle breeze flows past him which you
could read as Marvis Essence comforting
him in this moment another way that the
force is seen as being tied with the
natural world everyone chants stowed and
Sky which seems like their way of
invoking this transition of the deceased
Spirit from the brick to the heavens and
that is literally what happens here as
marva's post-mortem recording is played
B beams it up from his head explaining
why he was so insistent to stay at
Martha's home last episode and didn't
want to be moved and why marva's body
was shown so closely from his point of
view her Essence was staying with him in
that moment also when her corpse was
taken out we saw bees translucent
reflection on the window hovering over
her body now it's reversed her
translucent form hovers over B she says
where you stand now I've been more times
than I can remember
I always wanted to be lifted
I was always eager always waiting to be
inspired
I remember every time it happened every
time the Dead
lifted me this has taken place on Rick's
Road the title of this episode this is a
street that Marva previously said she
used to avoid because it's where Clem
was hanged and she didn't want to be
reminded of that so in her pre-death
moments she is pondering feeling like
she was already dead lifted up beside
Clem Her speech is beautiful and it cuts
deep the Empire is a disease that
thrives in dogs which is never More
Alive than when we sleep yeah casting
the Empire as a disease Echoes the way
Party Guys describe the Rebellion we are
Healthcare Providers we treat sickness
we identify symptoms we look at Joe
whether they arise from within or have
come from the outside the longer we wait
to identify a disorder the harder it is
to treat the disease and Marva closes
it's easy for the dead to tell you to
fight and maybe it's true maybe fighting
is useless perhaps it's too late but
I'll tell you this if I could do it
again
I'd wake up early and be fighting
these bastards work from the start
the empire
things about beauty shots delivery there
one hurried on bastards and two the
profanities she said that you didn't
hear because look closely at Fiona's
mouth on Fight The Empire fight the
Empire yes she did not enunciate the
word fight there the teeth do not come
down to make the tea it was a back of
the mouth consonant there she definitely
said
the Empire it looks like they dubbed it
with fight and they used the projector
glitch in a little bit to mask it just
think about it Bee's adorable stutter
helped cover marva's body mouth and the
Disney sensors shut it down by knocking
over the projector and knocking over
this precious Droid breaks the damn
Brasso uses marva's brick to smash the
guard so if you think about it Marvel
herself was literally among the first
punches here Wilman throws his explosive
and it knocks over a bit of grenades
causing a devastating chain reaction
that kills nurtchy and the blast blows
out bix's windows because before she was
reflecting to leave herself because she
was so traumatized but that deafening
blast finally cleared the sounds of the
dysonite screams from her head long
enough for her to leave Tebow orders the
Stormtroopers to fire at will and it's
so harmful to see all these people get
gunned down including an elderly
daughter of barracks and Zan in a rage
jumps on a stormtrooper and gets shot
himself the camera stays on him for
several seconds forcing us to take it in
the time Grappler continues to Pound The
Anvil to call more people to join the
mob and that Stormtrooper tries to stop
him gets a full Leonidas kick does ass
fire and a reminder that this time
Grappler is played by Neil Bell who
played the badass starter car leader in
dennyville news Dune Cyril saves Dedra
From the Mob and I love how Denise Goff
plays this moment terrified overwhelmed
with emotion trying to keep her cool and
thank God these two do not kiss I don't
think I could handle that Cassian and
Bix Meetup with Brasso and Jazzy B and
Willman and pelga planning to retreat to
ganji Moon stay low all the way to Far
Side sea the moment you get over the
water you climb uh there's that word
again climb nimics ordered a Cassian to
escape aldani kinos ordered all the
prisoners to escape in k2so's final word
to Cassian on scarif in Rogue one and
notice the ships and zorbee's shipyard
include the cockpit of a y-wing it's
painted yellow but its back engines are
not fully intact maybe it's
mid-transition from the earlier model
btly Wing Starfighter on the right being
a blue and white is the same model as
the best Dune Legacy that's Ochi bastoon
Starship in the rise of Skywalker and
then the back on the right is the bcx100
light braider that's the same model as
the ghost Harrison doula's ship and
Rebels Monmouth and Perrin hand off
their daughter laida to pavos Golden and
his son and that little culty girl is
into it notice how mon now wears blue
and gold the colors of house golden to
Mark her consent to this gross Union
Cassian gives Luther the option to shoot
him what game is this
okay kill me or take me in and Luther
Smiles because he's reminded of what he
told Cassian in this same spot back in
episode four wouldn't you rather give it
all at once to something real then carve
off useless pieces to this nothing left
the post credit scene conver
T an Arcane of 5
to 1905 these Droids are grouped
together to load each one into place
part of the same exact assembly line as
all those prisoners were as was the case
in Rogue one they used scale so well to
convey the immensity of the Death Star
which we start small and close up to
give a sense of each individual part and
pull back more and more and more to show
each of these massive pieces coming
together to form the death star's Focus
dish a piece that we'll finally see
lower into place in one of the early
shots of Rogue one now the planet
background is definitely scarif you can
see the same exact land mass in the
water where the Scarab face will be
built in that movie so it is confirmed
that Cassie can help build the weapon
that will one day be used to kill him
but the riot he helped orchestrate did
help delay the death star's construction
just long enough for the rebels to get
their hands on the schematics that they
can use to bring this battle station
down I so so loved Andor and I hope
these breakdowns helped you appreciate
that Easter eggs aren't always obvious
stuff like loaf cats and lightsabers
sometimes there's just cool attention to
detail hidden to norvash and I will
always appreciate Andor for making a
great Star Wars story not out of
nostalgia for other titles but really
out of its own great character
development and its own great story 10
out of 10. hey if you want to see me
live along with Tommy Bechtel Jessica
Clemens Brandon Barrick and Zach
Huddleston we will be at the LA Comic
Con this Sunday December 4th I would
love to be able to geek out with you in
person come meet us and hang out you can
follow me on Tick Tock Instagram Twitter
and now Hive at EA boss follow me
Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]